hello freak [ __ ] we have prejudice
yeah we want to believe we really want
to believe just like the x-files but
eventually when nature tells us
otherwise we throw out those beliefs
like yesterday's newspaper that's why
scientists still need now people that
are listening is probably going what is
gauge symmetry dude you just passed over
that you said it was crazy okay is there
a way that you could possibly just well
I mom yes and I'm sure I'll give I'll
try we'll see how we do okay so so it
turns out that that there's a
fundamental principle in nature which
which really was discovered by this
wonderful woman mathematician emmy
noether who was who wasn't even God to
get a job is she because she was a woman
in the turn of the century but she
discovered so there's things we say and
we tell kids unfortunately in schools
energy is conserved and momentum is
driven it sounds like the ten
commandments like we come up with them
because we liked them and now we
understand them differently we
understand that everything that is
conserved it doesn't change in the world
is due to a fundamental symmetry of
nature so energy is conserved because we
now understand the laws of physics don't
change over time so as long as you can
test that the laws of physics are too
same tomorrow as they are today then we
know energy is conserved it's not
something we take on faith it's a
mathematical consequence of that
momentum conservation is a consequence
of the fact that the laws of physics
don't change in place to place that
there same in this studio here as they
would be if we're having this
conversation in New York that seems
reasonable and she showed mathematically
it's the case so there's a there's a
famous everyone's experiences you know
learned any physics conservation of
charge you know the electric charge in
any system doesn't change magically over
time that's a fundamental property of
electricity and magnetism you got
something I'm going to charge at the
beginning it's got to be the same at the
end that's a consequence of the fact
that it's arbitrary there's a symmetry
of nature that says you know Benjamin
Franklin called electrons you know
negative negatively charged but it
doesn't mean anything because I could
have called them positively charged it's
just an arbitrary definition if I
changed every negative charge in the
world to positive charge and every
positive charge to negative
charge everything would work the same
way a symmetry of nature represents
something that doesn't change about
nature when you make a change in a
definition so making every calling
electrons positively charged and protons
negatively charged would not make the
world difference it's an arbitrary name
Martians could call electrons positively
charged and protons negatively charged
there's nothing fundamentally important
about the word positive charge it
doesn't mean any different than a
negative charge so I could change every
right now I can make all neg I could
change the charge on every electron the
universe and flip it it's signed so
every electron is negatively charged now
but now suddenly I'm God and I make
every electron positively charged and I
make every proton negatively charged
nothing about the laws of physics will
change I don't understand that why would
why wouldn't it change I mean this is
there a function of them being positive
or negatively you don't know it's just a
name that's why it's like it's like that
I can calm you down and down up and they
wouldn't make it as long as it's a noise
you make with your mouth yeah exactly
it's art so the name I give it is
irrelevant okay so it's not like you
would change the actual function of the
electron no no exactly I call it's it's
electrically charged that's important
okay and it repels other other electrons
because they have the same electric
charge that's important right right
electrically negative charged particles
repel right but look if I made them both
to positive charge particles they'd also
repel so so the physical consequences
would not change at all depending upon
how I named them I see okay now so the
example I use in the book to try and
exhorting describe that is a chess board
you got white squares and black squares
and you play with the white chess men of
the web if I changed all the white
squares into black squares and I rotated
the board by 90 degrees it would look
identical and if I change the black
players to white players and white
players black beard players the game of
chess would be identical nothing would
change about it so what's white and
what's black is kind of arbitrary right
matter which is good because if it kind
of wasn't then chess wouldn't be a fun
game because if you always had black you
might win if you always had white you
might win but it's it's the same right
right so so I could change all white
squares to black squares and blacks
whereas two white squares and the game
of chess would not change so that's a
symmetry of the chessboard and that's
like that's like electric charge white
being negative or positive and black
being you know so let's say I make say
white is negative and black is positive
if I switched all black to white or
negative positive nothing would change
about the game of chess if I switch
negative to positive in the universe
nothing changes in the universe the game
of life the game of physics would not
change
okay rules wouldn't change the the
dynamics everything would remain the
same about the universe so that you
could sort of even that is not so easy I
can tell from looking at your face it's
already not so easy okay but but you
couldn't sort of accept that yes okay
okay
that's the easy part okay so here's what
gauge symmetry says man this is really
weird I can actually do better than that
I can arbitrarily change each white
square in a chess board to a black
square
I can choose randomly which white
squares to change the black squares and
I can still make the game of chess the
same if I just have a rulebook and the
rulebook tells me oh if you're on that
square you can do what you could have
done if it was a white square so if I
have the rulebook then it doesn't matter
what colors the squares are if I know I
was in the square that used to be white
but I call black and I look at I say
okay my my knight can do this and that
square but I couldn't do that right so
if I have a rulebook then what then I've
arbitrarily free to change the color of
each square in a chessboard as long as a
rule book tells me what I've done right
that's that's electromagnetism because
it turns out electromagnetism has a
symmetry that says you know what I could
change the definition of the charge on
an electron here but in the next room
differently so I could call this
electron positive and that one negative
and it wouldn't change anything as long
as I had a rulebook that told me that I
made that change and how and how the
electromagnetic interaction would be the
same as long as I I'm free to change the
definition of what I call positive and
negative charge locally not globally
that means I can do it differently here
and there as long as I have a rulebook
that says you know what that electron
used to be negative so it'll still repel
this electron
here even though I call it positive and
I call that negative I changed locally
the definition but I also changed the
rules I understand that and then on the
need for the rule book now it turns out
that the rule book really tells you it's
a rule at each point in space right it's
a rule tells you what you can and can't
do at each point in space so we call
that a function because a function is a
number or a rule at each point in space
a function at space is exactly that well
it turns out the function that does that
is the electromagnetic field if you ask
what would be the mathematical
characteristics of a quantity that would
make sure the rules remain the same no
matter what I called an electron a place
to place and you ask how I could write
down mathematically it would have
exactly the mathematical form of the
electromagnetic field the thing that
that we call the electric field or
magnetic field the mathematics of it is
precisely fixed by being able to allow
us to change the definition of charge
from place to place in a way that
doesn't change the ultimate dynamics
doesn't change the way the world works
its prescribed by the mathematics of the
rulebook is prescribed and the
mathematics that rulebook
turns out magically almost to be exactly
the mathematics of Maxwell's equations
which are the equations of
electromagnetism here's where it gets
squirrelly for me okay why would you do
that why would you definitions why would
you need that rulebook well because I
mean what it says is that nature somehow
has this symmetry it doesn't depend what
you don't want to but it says nature
Nature has designed itself such that the
definition of electric charge from place
to place is arbitrary it really came if
you want to step back
Einstein told us you know that length
and time are kind of relative - they
depend upon the observer and and his
theory of general relativity actually
said I can define locally what my
coordinate system is what my length is
what my time is I can define that
arbitrarily locally and it may differ
from place to place my rulers could
differ from place to place but the work
that the universe doesn't care because
there's this thing called a
gravitational field that
takes into account of that and nature
has that symmetry so it doesn't matter
if I change the rulebook if I change the
what I define is space and time locally
the universe behaves exactly the same so
when you say by symmetry do you mean
essentially there's a balance that
there's always going to be an equal
numbers of negatives and positives are
not exchanged that's what the functions
of each one well it balances itself out
as well that's sort of a consequence it
says that the universe can't be charged
and ultimately but no it really says
that that's that's a quality of nature
that Nature doesn't care about namely
you that's a you let that's a label but
Nature has a symmetry in physics
symmetries are things when you make
changes they don't then the object
doesn't you take a sphere okay a sphere
you can rotate it but it looks like the
sphere no matter what rotation you make
right that's a symmetry of the sphere
that's why it's so beautiful and
mathematically nature is the same way I
can take another quantity I'll call it
electric charge at this point and I can
change it if you want to say make a
rotation in some internal space I can
imagine an internal space of positive
and negative charges were part of some
continuum I make a rotation and nature
doesn't care about it it's a symmetry of
the equations that govern nature but it
turns out the reason this is important
let me step back again because your face
tells it all I wish to people can see it
they can yeah yeah and so what we've
discovered is that the playing field
determines the rules the characteristics
of the playing fields the terminals if
baseball if you played baseball and
there were five bases instead of four
the rules would be different if the
distance between home plate and first
base was a mile the rules would be
different if you had 25 out of fielder's
and out in outfield it would be
different okay so the playing field
determines the rules right
you can't baseball the very different
game if we're played on a field that's
different what we've discovered in
nature is we used to think the forces
were kind of fundamental you know Newton
told us F equals MA and all that what we
discovered is the thing that really
constrains what can happen in the world
is the playing field
and the characteristics of the playing
field and for physicists what determines
the characteristics of a playing field
are the symmetries of that playing field
in fact baseball the fact that looks
like a diamond is a symmetry right I can
the playing field looks the same
I could call first base home plate and
home play first base if I rotated the
whole field right it determines in some
sense that's that's a characteristic of
baseball that sort of determines the
rules of the game okay and what we've
learned is what's really fundamental in
nature is the characteristics of that
playing field and what determines the
characteristics that playing fields are
the symmetries of nature the things that
that demonstrate to us that what we
think is fundamental is really just an
arbitrary label like electric charge ism
is an arbitrary label locally as well as
globally and that determines the whole
nature of the forces that can happen
once you say the electric charge is an
arbitrary thing and nature doesn't care
what you call positive and negative from
here or Mars that determines the nature
of the force of what we call the
electromagnetic force it's completely
prescribed and it turns out that's true
for all the forces in nature the nature
of gravity is determined as Einstein
showed by the fact that you can change
what I define as one meter here and on
Mars call one meter something else and
nature doesn't care what I label as a
meter it turns out gravity takes it that
into account and says what we define as
length is irrelevant the fundamental
gravitational field is due to a
curvature of space that that is
independent of what we define as length
or time locally it's a weird thing but
it's a property of space and time that
Einstein discovered for general
relativity we've discovered it for
electromagnetism it turns out all the
forces nature respect that same kind of
same kind of mathematical symmetry that
there's some quantity that you can
change in your equations I can change
its definition in equations but the
physics remains the same and the nature
of the equations just is prescribed the
mathematical form of the first great
equations is prescribed
precisely by the requirement that I can
change in the case of electric charge
that electric charge is arbitrary I can
call an electron positive or negative
anywhere I want space and the equations
don't care that prescribes the four
performance equations they have to have
a very particular form a unique form and
that unique form happens to be the form
that it has now so you can say look it's
an accident that really there's
something fundamental that the equations
have this form and lo and we've
discovered this mathematical symmetry as
an accident or you can say that the
mathematical symmetry is fundamental
it's a property of nature and it
prescribes the form of the kind of
forces that nature that the world allows
when you say that the the that it's
fundamental that the symmetry is
fundamental do you see this image do you
study like ecosystems do you study like
I know about them but I mean but you
ever contemplate them when you're
thinking about theoretical physics and
when you ever look at like how these
animals sort of stay in balance in these
ecosystem aspects when they're untouched
well I mean the mathematics of I mean
that's the great thing about physics
about science in general it's it's kind
of like Hollywood if it works you copy
it and and so we often find the same
mathematical formalism supply to vastly
different systems so there's a very
famous set of equations of predator and
prey for ecosystems and and and you can
look at those equations and they're the
same kind of equations that apply in
many different systems and in in the in
oatmeal boiling and also it's amazing
how the same mathematics appears in very
different systems and we can therefore
use what we learned in one case to apply
to another that's why we copy it because
it works so broadly it's amazing that
very few equations turn out to so
broadly describe so many vastly
different systems and predator-prey
relationships which is I think what
you're talking about in ecosystems how
you know there's a very anything with
plants as well I mean I mean I mean like
the full system yeah once you panic
becomes more complicated when you
include more variables but physics of
course is generally much easier than
many ecosystems that's why I do physics
it's so much easier it's because it's
really the low-hanging fruit nature and
anything for you well I know but but but
for most people listen
probably a hundred people that have
driven into trees by now yes like what
and the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
I'm glad it's people like you out there
that are particularly they can feel good
that the laws of physics are independent
whether they've run into the trees yes
that makes me I'm sure that gives them
great comfort yeah exactly
it's just
[Applause]
[Music]